out of nowhere I got a tax from one of
my roommates and was like Hey Matt's
parents died in a fire last night and
that was all it said and I was like whoa
so I texted him back and I was like well
is he okay and the next text I got was
they think he did it and I was like
what so they called and were like yeah
the cops came to the house last night at
like two in the morning and arrested him
and took everyone out of the house that
was there he went there and did all this
and then he drove back to Old Town and
went back to sleep at our apartment we
were renting this [__] dude that you
lived with murdered his entire family
and then drove back to your place and
went to sleep to sleep
the Honeydew with y'all subscribe today
[Music]